welcome to New York guys I'm Jason Inman
and I'm Tiffany Smith and we've got an
inside look at the new animated movie
Batman bad blood and I promise we won't
make any Taylor Swift jokes yeah Taylor
Swift jokes are so 1989 get ready for DC
all-access
DC blew our minds is an amazing 30th
anniversary Dark Knight Returns panel at
New York Comic Con last week please
welcome the Dark Knight himself mr.
Frank Miller Frank Miller himself made a
surprise appearance and if you couldn't
make it to the panel check out our
exclusive coverage of the event tomorrow
vertigo continues to roll out their 12
new titles with the Twilight children at
number one Gilbert Hernandez and Darwin
cook team up to tell the tale of a
mysterious white orb that completely
opens life in a small latin-american
village you can grab your copy starting
tomorrow the new series Superman Lois
and Clark features DC's original power
couple living a new world
Superman is trying to prevent his
enemies from taking hold in his new home
while also keeping his nine-year-old son
safe issue number one flies on the store
shelves this week Batman bad blood is
the latest blockbuster from DC animation
and it features the premiere of that
woman and batwing and right now we've
got to look at the exclusive trailer
I'm gonna show a Gotham whose top dog
around here
if that's your best Batman you're not
gonna fall anywhere Grayson there's no
way you're gonna pull this off without
my help if Batman doesn't return soon
I know all bloody hell's gonna break
loose
we should work together his family this
isn't gonna be easy
just follow my lead he wanted to create
the perfect soldier
I was the strongest of them all
I don't trust her just because I wear
this doesn't mean I'm a part of you cold
call me back wait
batwing that's original we're just
getting started
from here on it's only family
basically it picks up with Batman
kicking ass right as he usually does as
he does very well and gets a little out
of his jab I'm just gonna tell you what
happens fat woman comes along and messes
everything up
no she doesn't she comes along but you
know she's using guns and that's not
really Batman's thing she gets herself
into a little bit of trouble Batman
sacrifices himself in order to save her
and has never seen or heard from again
is that all the beginning of this movie
did you just spoil most of it that is
the opening two minutes of her and so
the bat family comes together
Damian comes back from the monastery
where he's trying to find himself
Nightwing has been trying to fill the
shoes of Batman but not doing a very
good job and along the way Luke Fox who
ends up being batwing and also
Battlement joined the fray and they try
to solve the mystery of what happened to
Batman I was the one that suggested him
so I feel very good about it I'm like
yeah I want that woman I want that way I
knew we were going to be doing a Batman
and a Justice League per year but within
that I wanted to introduce at least one
or two new characters to each franchise
and so for this one it was great to be
able to introduce that woman and that
way this is the first time we're seeing
him on screen at all so it's really cool
he becomes part of the family and when
you see batwing he's just taking on the
role so he hasn't there's like room for
him to develop and hopefully you know
they'll be sequels and we'll get to see
him kind of mature into the role we know
that there's the bat family team in this
one but there's also a villains team yes
so how much fun was it for you to draw
those characters and create some new
looks for them that's like the best part
of my job the villains tend to be more
fun sometimes because you could play so
much more Killer Moth is a good example
he was a lot of fun to do and we have
such a cool rogues gallery just henchmen
that we that we threw in for visual
spice to add flavor to the action
there's so many cool like lesser known
characters hopefully we you know shine a
little light on them talk to me a little
bit about the pressure of taking on a
role that's never been in animated films
before and it's your first time yeah
we feel a lot of pressure I really felt
like it was a great honor to kind of
bring some life to this character
because you know other people have
talked about how so many characters have
been done over the years you know from
like Batman back in the day I used to
watch Adam West as a kid I was huge into
on the Batman animated series so there's
been you know people who played Batman
over the years but to step into a brand
new character I just thought it was a
really cool honor to kind of give it my
own spin and have a first crack at it
when I'm on way into a voice session I
like talk as Batman in the car but like
even if I'm going through a
drive-through I'm like and make it extra
cheese no you don't I'm sorry we need to
like be in the car with you the next
time you're going to vo session just so
we can experience that I said medium
soda you gave me regular that's all the
news for today but for more DCL access
and coverage of dark night 3 check out
some of those videos over there and make
sure you click Subscribe so you can
check out our exclusive video from the
Dark Knight Returns 30th anniversary
panel from New York Comic Con tomorrow
that's a lot of dark night gonna be on
and dark